[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
première question juste est-ce que vous
êtes soulager de toutes ces
avant-première qui se passe plus que
bien on rigole beaucoup c'est très
familiale on s'amuse écoute concernant
les avant-premières j'avoue que ça se
passe très bien et que ça fait plaisir
de voir autant de monde venir voir le
film rire de dire des choses si gentille
après avoir le film est toujours pas
sorti donc voilà mais en tout cas pour
l'instant ça se passe super bien
effectivement quand tu vas aux
avant-premières tu as toujours ce stress
de dire est-ce que le film va plaire
plus que les autres manque les autres
voilà et pour l'instant tout se passe
très bien je m'appelle Cédric je suis
comédien et je viens de passer le
casting de ma vie à la base j'étais pas
le premier jour
passe un petit coup de pouce du destin
Batman c'est moi
le premier super-héros
français sur le pitch on en a pas parlé
donc un apprenti comédien et qui
décroche enfin un premier rôle de
circonstances qui devient Badman un
accident il confond fiction fiction et
réalité s'identifier à son personnage on
s'en vous vous amusez tousse beaucoup
j'aimerais juste avoir la vidéo des
photos aussi au milieu de tous ces
garçons vous vous amusez beaucoup aussi
du
coup donc on s'est éclaté
pas beaucoup
pour moi
les super-héros que vous vous posez dans
l'écriture où est-ce que ça vient tout
seul les références à tous ses films se
dire que effectivement on aime mettre
des petits clins d'œil plus ou moins
évident pour les gens qui connaissent
les films de super-héros
et après une autre blague qui venait de
façon naturelle et après il y en a c'est
vrai ça serait bien quand même de place
et ce personnage là où c'est parce que
c'est que c'est très emblématiques et du
coup on essaie de trouver à quel moment
dans quelle scène place et ça donc voilà
un peu de un peu de deux je peux pas
prendre de risques
[Musique]
commander tous les spermatozoïdes avec
le premier travailler sur l'écriture
globale du film aussi avec un stylo et
un papier non ça c'est
on se retrouve toujours chez Philippe et
sa compagne
qui est contente de nous
accueillir des gens et on est quatre à
écrire donc pierre Lachaud le petit
frère de fille fille qui adore qu'on a
pas le petit frère et Pierre Dudan Fifi
et moi et on écrit c'est assez scolaire
on se retrouve le matin on travaille
toute la journée des fois il y a plein
d'idées d'autres fois il y en a moins
voilà et on a un parasite qui vient et
qui écrit sur des fois on a un peu peur
Birds qui écrit le prénom de son
personnage par exemple à Éléonore
Éléonore fait la bagarre Éléonore tape
sur voilà je ne citerai pas je ne dirai
pas qui c'est sur le département quand
même un mot pour le pour le département
des Yvelines département où vous avez
grandi
vous aimez bien revenir aussi sur le
département vous saluer souvent
professeur la dernière fois moi j'ai vu
le film à Plaisir avant-première à
Plaisir professeur de sport qui était
présent
et du coup
dans les Yvelines on est hyper content
ça nous touche et puis ça me fait
quelque chose donc c'est un important
pour nous non il y a La
Celle-Saint-Cloud donc nous avez cinéma
à l'époque c'était cinéma de Parly 2 on
y aller tout le temps et puis voilà on y
aller en bande et tout donc ouais retour
aux sources à 9h sur ce film-là je
voulais juste te voir par rapport au
prochain si vous avez déjà l'idée du
prochain ma question est un peu orienter
je vais regarder sur internet des gens
ont déjà des idées le prochain ça serait
une adaptation de d'Astérix par la bande
à Fifi j'ai vu un sondage sur
mesopinions.com il y a 3 signatures pour
cette adaptation est-ce que c'est une
bonne idée ou pas 3 s'il y a
[Rires]
un moment
voilà
avec tes beaux-parents
[Musique]
juste une dernière question est-ce qu'il
y aura une suite ou non à Nicky Larson
je vous pose la question parce que j'ai
trois filles à la maison qui ont vu
chacune des films et qui me le demande
une question tu me connaissais pas et du
coup moi je peux échanger dessus mais
c'est que Nicky Larson c'est pas le film
qu'on a fait qui a le plus marché ça a
marché mais c'est pas celui qui a le
plus marcher et je crois que c'est le
film dans les avant-première du faire 50
salle aujourd'hui on nous demande à
chaque fois sur une suite à Nico que
c'est que il y aura au moins 53
personnes avec tes filles
mais ça fait plaisir parce que le projet
avec tellement été un peu à l'annonce
pas la sortie mais à l'annonce que du
coup ça fait plaisir avec un parallèle
avec
éventuellement
[Musique]
mon frère se prend pour le personnage de
son film